كانت شركه اديداس تسجل النتائجك كارثيه في
وجه منافستها نايكي في كاس العالم 2022
لكن فوز الارجنتين بالكاس قلب الطاوله
الحرب بين اديداس ونايكي وبدرجه الاقل
بوما في كل نسخه من كاس العالم لا تقل
شراسه عن التنافس بين المنتخبات الكبرى
فكل فوز لفريق يعني مبيعات بالملايين
للشركات التي تصنع زياره الرسمي بدايه يجب
ان نعرف ان هذه الحرب تجري على ملعب
اديداس وبين جمهورها في كونها شركه
الالمانيه ثم مبيعتها تتركز في اوروبا
السوق الاكبر لكره القدم بينما تتفوق هناك
في لعبه كره السله وموطنها الاكبر
الولايات المتحده لكن في كاس العالم 2022
كانت الصوره مختلفه انفقت معك لما يقاربوه
148 مليون دولار كنافه السوقيه الاكبر
مقابله 95 مليون دولار من اديداس واحد 11
مليون دولار منكوما وكانت هذه المره
الثالثه فقط في التاريخ التي تتفوق فيها
على اديداس في عدد المنتخبات وتبتدي
يزيعها في كاس العالم بعد مونديال 2006
و2/2014 بدات مايكل مونديال بثلاثه عشر
منتخبا ترتدي قمصانها من بينها اسماء
كبيره مثل البرازيل وفرنسا وانجلترا
وهولندا وكرواتيا مقابله سبع منتخبات
الاديداس وستفهما لكن اديداس كانت تراهم
على اربعه منتخبات الكبرى في محفظتها
مرشحه للوصول للنهائي وهي المانيا
واسبانيا والارجنتين وبلجيكا مبدئيا كانت
اديداس تتوقعوا مبيعاتا بنحو 415 مليون
دولار مرتبطه لكاس العالم
لكن الضربه الكبرى للاديدا من خروجي
المانيا الصادم من دوري المجموعات وكذلك
خروج بلجيكا على يد المغرب في المقابل لم
تكن السعيده بخروج البرازيل ربع
النهائي امام كرواتيا مع ان هذا المنتخب
ضمن محفظتها اما بوما فكانت جميع
المنتخبات التي ترتدي زيها غير مرشحه
لبلوغ ادوار المتقدمه لكن المفاجاه الكبرى
السعيده لها كانت وصول المغربي الى نصف
نهائي بالتالي كان النهائي عباره عن
مباراه بين نايكي في صفي فرنسا واديداس في
صوفيا الارجنتين ومع فوز الارجنتين بالكاس
العالم تعول اديداس على مبيعات هائله
لخميس الارجنتين بالنجمات الثلاث وخصوصا
باسمي ميسي فهل تكون النجمه الثالثه لميسي
كافيه لتعويض خروج المانيا المبكر
[تصفيق]